is there another email I need something
to respond to yes my name is Jim and I'm
21 years old a couple years ago my
brother and I were diagnosed with a
neurodegenerative illness that has
already subscrip has affected our
physical abilities in one day we will
leave us entirely paralyzed oh man I
lost my job not long ago after my
diagnosis and has a disability support
worker I haven't worked since I'll need
a wheelchair soon and I'm told we
probably won't live much past 30 I used
to sing play guitar drums and piano
however I now no longer can do any of
that this has contributed to my current
depression I like to write fanfiction
and want to pursue that further although
between my depression all the weed I
smoke I find it hard to even get out of
bed how do you think I can turn my life
around and do something with myself
before it's too late
thanks tiger belly is just papaya Jim
alright 21 will be paralyzed in 30
alright so and what does he mean how do
I change this before it's too late like
he wants to do you think he wants to
make something of his life is trying to
get it straight something before he's
unable to physically yeah the only thing
that I could say is if I was in that
situation what I would do is since he
does listen to our podcast he probably
listens to other ones I would do one hmm
that's a good that's right I would do a
podcast talk about because you now know
that you you you're what you have a debt
10 years right right so you can talk
about you know your feeling about that
you know me you can have guests on with
other I think would be very like
positive because I tell you what you'd
feel fulfilled especially if you're a
creative guy what you see played the
yeah so yeah you'd feel fulfilled when I
started my podcast I didn't think I was
gonna like it and I really liked it and
it feels really good yeah so he should
try that especially if he listens to
podcasts which he does so yeah and I
also think that like it's something
that's never been done and I think that
other people with you know ailments or
it what's true you had the could you
know listen to it and feel you know
positive and you can lasting impact yeah
have a lasting impact I think that I
would do that if that was me mm-hmm
right but I think that's sitting around
doing nothing is not good you know
there's a I'll get I'm gonna tell you a
movie it's a movie called akiro mm-hmm
it's a it's a Kurosawa film and it's
about a it was I think the movie would I
know but can I just this is you know
what are you two laughing like that this
side and you two
that's that you're gonna get I'm gonna
get you back for that revenge from my
part okay that was that was you nothing
on my side and that was very funny by
the way
okay Carol that was that that [ __ ] was
for that kid man I know
thank you kid but listen to what I have
to say now and this is the last thing
I'm gonna say okay I promise and you can
go and live your life all right dude
okay Accuro and it's about a guy who's a
government worker in Japan in the 1940s
it was an old movie it was I think
filmed in 1950 okay black-and-white film
so you watch it like when you were three
or something no I watched it and I want
to come out when it came out really
funny yeah okay that's very funny but I
said you know and it's all good but to
get a Denny's in this fine but the
movies about a guy he has no family or
anything really no friends he just about
be working at this government position
office job and he has no no friends
really just shows up to work every day
yeah but he gets stomach cancer okay and
he doesn't know who to tell because he
has no loved ones and he would still go
to work but have this pain in the
stomach and what he did was as a
government worker he opened up a park
for children
in the movie it gave him something to do
work towards he wanted to you know do
something for Humanity so he fought hard
and at the end of the movie he's
swinging on the swing set
yeah I think he's whistling or singing
and then he dies right right but um
yeah do the podcast or no arc strangely
that was very poignant even though you
[ __ ] it up a little by the end but
yeah how do i [ __ ] said anyway do the
podcast yeah yeah but I mean that just
mother I appreciate the way you'd said
it the whole time hey you know what dude
thank you for even doing that be
appreciative appreciative you for being
here thank you I appreciate you having
me here and I appreciate you
appreciating me I have a big nose yeah
[Music]